[Música]
mi abuelo nació en 1891 en el salvador
en una familia militar su papá era
general del ejército
le dieron una educación muy buena bien
los años 30 lo mandaron a italia a
estudiar a una escuela militar muy buena
que estaba el torino ahí comenzó los 30
tiempos en europa con esta educación
pues él subió hasta el el grado de
coronel y comandante del año 33 después
de estar en el torino y después regresó
a el salvador ya fue no regresa
una matanza de indígenas desarmador y él
se opuso a esto y comenzó a escribir
contra esta injusticia que el gobierno
de el salvador de este tiempo un
gobierno totalitario y entonces por esto
el gobierno como él era muy apreciado
por el ejército y era muy influencia y
entonces el presidente de el salvador
que se llamaba mejía emiliano hernández
martínez lo mandó a otra vez a europa y
en europa lo manda a varias misiones una
idea de comprar las armas para el
ejército
y en una de esas misiones conoce y
conoce a un amigo que es judío
y quién es el otro protagonista de esta
historia los judíos se llamaba jorge
mandó después que cambió el nombre a
george marcado entonces en el año 1938
mi abuelo lo mandó a servir como cónsul
en hamburgo
[Música]
para crear el libro de mi hermano cuando
estaba en 38 mi hermanos mi abuelo
perdón comenzó a dar pistas que salvaron
la vida de muchas personas y después
junto con su amigo judío que mencionó mi
hermano dieron
también unos documentos salvadoreños que
salvaron la vida de miles y desde eso se
destaca la historia de mi abuelo ya
estando afuera del país él se sentía
como
un día se puede decir
indignado por lo que estaba pasando en
el país él miraba que el nivel de país
nelson de fascismo
y después llegó al corazón de fascismo
en europa porque el principio fue
inglaterra después a alemania durante la
guerra entonces el primer la primera
razón que pensamos nosotros es por
combatir el fascismo tanto en
latinoamérica como en alemania él
decidió rescatar personas y desobedecer
él está en una posición especial porque
era diplomático entonces él podía tenía
ningún sentido se puede decir que tenía
un poco de inmunidad y podía hacer algo
para el psoe del ser
a su país desde las órdenes que tenían
en observar personas y lo hicieron
cuando sting a mente con este documento
yo creo que la primera razón fue por
combatir el fascismo pero después él
y con mucho la causa de salvar vidas se
trata nuestra película
[Música]
y